all right Ashley
you're under arrest for a sexual battery
of a monitor
um
a disturbing story out of Oklahoma where
a teenager is arrested after allegedly
taking sexually explicit photos and
videos of her boyfriend's three-year-old
daughter
you're an arrest body camera video shows
the arrest of 19 year old Ashley
Cheatham who was taken into custody on
August 22nd in Stillwater Oklahoma the
video shows officers approach her door
after nearly 30 seconds Cheatham
approaches the door telling officers
she's not wearing any clothes
[Music]
okay you actually what's your last name
okay
still officials take Cheatham into
custody almost immediately
you're interested prior to her arrest
cheatham's boyfriend contacted police
saying he discovered a series of
shocking photos and videos on her phone
while she was sleeping he said the video
showed Cheatham abusing his
three-year-old daughter in a press
release Stillwater police called him a
quote very distraught parents
cheatham's boyfriend explained he met
her online saying the couple had just
moved in together video shows Cheatham
apparently frazzled after she's
handcuffed as First Responders search
for a pair of pants for her to put on
there you go
now are there jeans or shorts or shorts
109.
32 player
victory
I literally just broke up I don't know
where is there a place where you want to
keep your shorts
yeah there's some right there those
pajama pants are findings
you got these formula like slip-on shoe
or anything
[Music]
they're like falling down
next investigators asked Cheatham
whether she wants to bring her ID
he's ready in your purse
20th century
that's why I came to sit in there okay
yeah success there
moments later officers explained why
Cheatham is being arrested all right
Ashley
you're under arrest for a sexual battery
of a minor
um
she now faces multiple charges including
sexual abuse of a child under 12. making
or Distributing obscene material or
child pornography possession of
marijuana and violation of Oklahoma
computer Crimes Act officials say
Cheatham later admitted to the crimes
she was booked into the Payne County
jail and received a protective order
prohibiting her from contacting the
alleged victim local TV stations report
that before her arrest Cheatham was in
the process of being hired at a local
elementary school a spokesperson for
that District says the hiring process
has since been called off reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie